OK, now that we've had a chance to sort of
calm down from that wild Jimmy from Philly
call, let's go back to the phone lines at
six one seven eight three zero forty seven
50 and see what's on people's minds, starting
with our caller from the nine to eight area
code who is calling today from nine to eight.
A David Scott.
Hey, Sean, what's going on?
I'm just curious why you know what you're
talking about.
So I know it's the bodies as Election Day
has to be the second Tuesday or whatever one
that's, I think, the way it's taken.
It's the first Tuesday after the first Monday.
So it couldn't be the first of a month, I
guess, is the idea.
Y y you know, we're talking about since that's
a law.
Why don't they just extend like I've always
questioned why it's not on a weekend anyway,
so why don't they talk about making it, you
know, a week instead of just one day?
OK.
Well, Peanut, what he planned.
We'll talk about mail.
And people do talk about either making Election
Day or a federal holiday, although it's unclear
the net benefit of that, because a lot of
people work on holidays anyway.
It would just kind of like change.
Who's able to vote?
There's a discussion about voting on the week.
The all of these things have been discussed,
but it's very difficult to do.
It certainly isn't going to happen between
now and November.
But is there some particular reason why you
think this time around it should be done?
Well, because we depend on a grade, you could
spread it out.
You could say, you know, if you have a last
name, 8D got it on Tuesday, you don't eat
a J. Wednesday, whatever.
So the easier way to do it legally would be
instead of extending voting to multiple days,
you would just start every day.
So right now, early voting in states that
have it, it's usually only a few polling places
and it's limited hours.
The way to do what you're suggesting, I think
Sean, would be on October 27.
We say polls open today and they will be open
through the end of November 3rd and give it
right.
So start with a full day early voting in all
polling places.
That would probably be the simplest way to
do it legally and logistically.
Right.
So instead of this stupid argument about Marilyn
Ballards and fraud, that's not going to happen.
Why don't the states just start talking about
that?
I've ever heard.
Yeah, I mean, it's not being discussed because
I just don't think most governors are going
to do it.
And logistically, to keep polling places,
you know, people volunteer months ahead of
time to do pull working on one day.
If you're going to say we're now going to
have seven days of poll work, I it is a logistical
nightmare and I get why it's not being discussed.
But as an idea, I think it's a good one.
All right.
Well, you don't think it's going to happen
ever that we extend to Election Day to more
than one day?
I don't think it's going to happen movie.
But I'm open to it.
You know, who can say what will happen in
the future?
Right, so basically, Democrats would have
to get have two thirds vote right in the Senate
in order for their lot to actually pass?
Well, it would probably be easier to do it
at the state level where, Governor, because
governors control early voting.
So you don't even have to do it in the Senate.
OK.
Galper.
All right.
OK.
Thank you.
Appreciate it.
People are thinking that's good.
I like to see that.